In our previous videos, we studied the structure
of a human eye and the
propagation of light through it.
There we saw that most of the light which
enters the eye is REFRACTED by the outer front
layer of the eye called the
cornea.
What does this biconvex lens do then?
It refracts light, yes, but its main objective
is to make sure that the image is
formed on the retina only.
By changing its shape, the lens controls the
direction of propagation of light.
This ability of the lens to change its focal
length is defined as the ACCOMMODATION POWER
of the eye.
This is
something we’d seen in the previous videos!
In this video, we will discuss few of the
most common eye defects.
Let’s start with Myopia first.
It is one of the most common eye defects and
it is
also called NEARSIGHTEDNESS.
It is a condition of the eye in which the
nearby
objects are visible clearly but the distant
objects are blurry.
How does the light
propagate inside a myopic eye?
Well the light from the nearer object travels
in the usual way.
It gets focussed
on the retina only.
No problems there!
What about the distant objects?
First of all the light rays from a faraway
object coming towards the eye are
almost parallel to each other.
And when these rays enter the eye, they get
converged IN FRONT of the retina instead of
ON the retina.
This is the reason
for blurriness.
But what causes the light to converge in front
of the retina
rather than ON the retina?
The larger size of the eye ball is one of
the reasons which results in this eye
defect.
Due to the elongated eye ball, the distance
between the lens and the
retina is more than the usual.
Because of this larger distance between the
two,
the image is formed in front!
Well one thing we must note here is that the
lens
functions in its usual way.
It does its work neatly as it is supposed
to!
The only
thing is that the image is formed at a different
position.
So how do we overcome this eye defect?
It can be corrected by using a
concave lens.
We place a concave lens in front of myopic
eye.
Why concave
lens?
We know that the concave lens diverges the
light!
And these divergent
rays fall on the lens at such an angle such
that they refract and come together
ON the retina.
Not in front of the retina!
Ok, so that was all about myopia!
Let’s quickly review what we learnt.
If a person is suffering from myopia, then
far away objects are not visible clearly.
That’s because the light rays after
entering the eye do not converge exactly on
the retina!
They converge at a
point in front of the retina!
So a concave lens helps fix this issue.
The rays
diverge, and the refracted rays from the lens
fall ON the retina!
The other most common eye defect and that
is Hyperopia.
What is hyperopia?
And have you heard of Presbyopia?
Watch the next lesson to know more!